so last night was the super bowl as you
may have heard it was a game between the
cincinnati bengals a team with no fans
at all outside of cincinnati and the los
angeles rams a team with no fans at all
anywhere outside los angeles or inside
ultimately the rams prevailed marking
the first nfl championship for a third
world country which i thought was was
was really nice truly it was inspiring
to see that even if la can't stop gangs
of hoodlums from ransacking stores and
committing violent crimes or you know
prevented sidewalks from becoming
homeless refugee camps or clean up the
trash that covers literally every square
inch of that putrid and hideous city
it can at least score enough points to
beat the bengals
as it happens the super bowl was
actually played in los angeles this year
requiring an impressive effort by the
city to clean up enough of the garbage
and use needles so that fans had space
to park their cars at least however
some people think that it isn't fair
that you know one of the teams competing
in the game
got to host the game as well
and i agree that it isn't fair there
shouldn't be any more home super bowls
which is why i think every super bowl
should be hosted in dc or dallas from
here on out because that way this will
never happen again
but in any case it was a good game i
must admit it was it was also along with
being a good game
a festival of rank hypocrisy
by the left now remember of course that
hypocrisy does not simply mean
doing one thing while saying another
that might not be hypocrisy at all that
might be simple cowardice or
inconsistency
hypocrisy is pretending to believe
things that you don't actually believe
and hypocrisy is endemic in our culture
which is a problem because it's
impossible to have meaningful debates or
come to any sort of understanding
between sides if so many of the people
involved in the conversation don't
actually believe anything that they're
saying
now if you've noticed that our debates
are almost always fruitless
and nobody is listening to anybody and
nothing comes of any of it
this is why
lots of people don't believe what
they're saying
they don't believe much of anything at
all i think
which brings us back to the super bowl
the biggest entertainment event of the
year an occasion for all of the
country's biggest corporations to spend
millions of dollars to make themselves
visible because they weren't visible
enough already while also parading their
wokeness around for the acceptance and
approval of the sorts of people who
pretend to be rebels against the system
that caters to their every emotional
whim
now it began with an in unexpectedly
respectful and well-executed national
anthem performance
something the nfl can get away with
because you know they have to get away
with doing a respectful national anthem
these days but they can get away with it
because they also make sure to include
the so-called black national anthem in
the broadcast
we are a country if you hadn't heard by
now with two national anthems
the original written by francis scott
key and then this other thing called
lift every voice and sing
the nfl must lay these sacrifices upon
the altar of wokeness so that the left
won't accuse it of racism because of
course an organization in which 60
percent of its athletes and the majority
of its most visible stars are black
has to constantly prove that it's not
racist
and the efforts are all in vain as
always
no matter what the nfl does
it will always be labeled racist
because that's how the game is played
the left derives much of its political
power from the phantom of racism they
will not let that phantom go no matter
how desperate and absurd the racism
claims have to be
speaking of which just as a side note
brian flores a story that we've been
tracking on this show he's the former
nfl head coach who's now suing the
league for systemic racism
just yesterday
uh before the super bowl he added the
houston texans to his lawsuit now he
alleges that the texans failed to hire
him because of their racism the
inconvenient detail here is that the
texans didn't hire him
because they wanted someone else
who was also black
they hired a black head coach
but it was the wrong black head coach
and so they're still racist
once again this is how the game is
played
but uh to the black national anthem uh
the the well yeah the not the national
anthem but the fake one the black
national anthem if you thought the idea
of a racially tribalized national anthem
couldn't get any more grotesque
wait until you see what it looked like
when they performed it watch
[Applause]
[Music]
that the dark past had taught
[Music]
does any other country in existence have
this by the way
before now lots of countries almost
every country before some big event
they're going to sing a national anthem
does any other country have two
you know if they've got the normal one
and then another one for a specific
racial group
but the singers there they were
performing with the accompaniment of the
la youth orchestra
and as you can see if you're if you're
watching on the uh the video podcast
the lead adult performers didn't have
masks on
the kids in the background did
there is something distinctly creepy and
dystopian about the sight of two adults
standing in front of a group of masked
faceless children
and it's a site we've gotten used to of
course that's also a site that isn't
going away anytime soon if you feel like
you are getting the respect you deserve
in life well i've got a solution for you
establish titles is your opportunity to
earn the title of lord or lady and gain
the respect you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
scotland in your title pack you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and the best
way to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends or boyfriends or even family
you can even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles is having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com matt walsh or just click the
link below at the game last night there
was not even an attempt by any of the
leftist luminaries in attendance to
pretend that they take masking seriously
just watch the announcers go through the
litany of celebrities in attendance and
notice what accessory is missing from
all of these people watch
we're in hollywood who do we got here we
got jay-z
matt damon
teresa wrong is here
[Music]
lebron
jennifer and ben
there you go there's my kind of
celebrity yeah now we're talking i mean
where else would they be
not a mask in sight all of them maskless
lebron james is wearing an entire
diamond mine around his neck but uh he
left the mask at home priorities i
suppose
and yet even as lebron and jennifer
lopez and ben affleck and all the rest
of them and matt damon
and the mayor of los angeles all partied
at the super bowl in a crowd of 75 000
revelers all without masks
children in the city are currently
sitting in classrooms fully masked
a festival of hypocrisy like i said
and we haven't even made it to the
halftime show
half halftime sponsored by
uh the aarp featured dr dre snoop dogg
eminem and 50 cent and also mary j blige
because they they knew they had to throw
a woman in there for appearances sake
but all these men are in their 40s and
50s all were wheeled out of their
retirement homes to perform their hit
songs from back when they were relevant
and to embarrass millennials with
children like myself by forcing us to
admit to our kids that we used to listen
to this kind of stuff
the timing of this performance was
interesting though
because here are dr dre snoop dogg
eminem
on the biggest entertainment platform in
the world
um
performing to universal acclaim and
adulation
this is happening after three weeks of
the left insisting that joe rogan
shouldn't have a platform anymore
because he said bad words a long time
ago
some might point out
that dr dre snoop dogg and eminem also
said bad words a long time ago and still
say bad words today in fact
not long before joe rogan began making
edgy jokes on his podcast
eminem was rapping about killing gay
people
he did that for like 10 years
that was his
he dedicated like three albums to it
yet he's allowed to have his platform
even the biggest platform and he's
allowed to stay on spotify without
objection by the way all these guys are
on spotify
i don't i don't when's the last time any
uh
any uh
other artist
so i'm pulling my my music from spotify
until eminem has taken off
but they're allowed to do this because
in recent years
especially eminem you know he's begun
making his own payments on the woke
altar
like this at the conclusion of the
performance eminem dramatically took a
knee
another payment was made
the media afterwards hailed the the move
congratulating the rapper for kneeling
to honor colin kaepernick
now you notice how they're not even
pretending that the knee thing has
anything to do with police brutality
anymore not even pretending
all the headlines are saying he was
kneeling to honor colin kaepernick
now that's why they do it
to honor a multi-millionaire nike brand
ambassador and media personality
it's a totally empty gesture and always
was of course
like everything else from the left
thus in its own way i suppose a fitting
tribute
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content